hi guys so this is kind of just an
announcement video I wanted to thank you
all so much because I just hit nine
hundred thousand subscribers here on
YouTube and I wasn't really gonna
celebrate until I had a million but I
was just really excited and I just
wanted to say thank you to everyone who
subscribes and asked you a question
what should I do when I hit a million I
have a few ideas of things that I want
to do but I want to see what you think I
should do so leave a comment below and
to let me know what you think I should
do when I hit a million subscribers the
second thing that I want to talk about
was the iPod giveaway contest that I'm
doing on my facebook comm slash I just
seen Facebook page now all you have to
do is click a like on my profile so if
you've liked my page you're entered and
no I don't care where you live you don't
have to be United States to me wherever
you have a Facebook page and you can
click the like button and I can see your
little profile picture in my view all
friends then you're entered and the
winner of the iPod Touch will also get a
custom video message from me unless you
don't want it then I won't record one
for you and the third thing that I want
to talk to you guys about is this
magazine right here the November issue
of Fast Company magazine that may or may
not have my face in it there's a really
great article in here that talks about
online influence and it also features
wait for it mystery guitar man huge
thanks to Mark Gordon for writing such a
great article and now I hope you guys
will go and pick it up and greet it
thank you guys so much again for all of
your support oh shoot there's one more
thing that I want to show you hold on
hold hold on oh I wanted to update you
guys on my progress of juggling four
balls not that I even told you that I
was teaching myself to juggle four but
I'm gonna update you on my progress and
nonetheless
it's utak it's taking me some breaths
I'm working on it anybody else juggle
four balls can you juggle three can you
juggle one good of those already easy
alright that's it guys I need to
practice juggling four balls because I
got the three down be sure to check out
facebook.com slash I just seen if you
want to be entered for that wonderful
iPod touch contest and don't forget that
I have another youtube channel
youtube.com slash other iJustine and
that's where I post like vlog because
some stuff like that because I post
there a lot so yeah anyway okay gonna go